hey kids I'll wait till we get a few
people there let it build up a little
bit but a man it's me and I'm fine
kind of I had a heart attack massive
heart attack and very nearly died the
other night Sunday night I was doing two
shows which we were shooting for a
comedy special and after the first show
which is great two hours and I was like
ah yet we got one more shows gonna be
great I started feeling nauseous fell
ill nauseous and then I tried to lay
down on the floor I was like hey man
I'll just lay down for a bit and when I
was laying down on the floor I wound up
getting ill like threw up and but mostly
bile so I just thought like you know I
got some bad milk that was it I was
honestly under the impression that I'd
gotten some [ __ ] bad milk so I went
to lay down at the theater at the Alex
theater and everyone there was very nice
and Jordan chases wife who runs our
company and Emily who does my hair we're
both there and they were like keeping an
eye on me and stuff and I was in that
sickly like I don't want I won't be
alone I was laying I'm laying in a dark
room and [ __ ] like that it's trying to
get over it so I can do the next show
once they loaded everybody in and then I
was like I want to lay down on the couch
is their couch anywhere so I went and
found a couch and I laid down on the
couch and flowers people nice people
didn't send flowers and stuff when laid
down on the couch and I couldn't get
comfortable which is weird for me like I
get comfortable anywhere and [ __ ] and I
could not get comfortable laying on my
stomach like I my back my sides and
stuff and then I started feeling
pressure on my chest but not like you
know there's no will fit on my chest I
just couldn't catch my breath honestly I
was never really in pain and even in the
ER they're like how much pain are you in
on a 1 to 10 I was like I'm not really
in pain I just couldn't catch my breath
so because of that and because I'm 47
like I didn't piece together heart
attack even when I was sitting there
going
like my chest is heavy and stuff and
even though my father died at age 67 of
a massive heart attack and even though
my mother has heart problems she has two
stents in her arteries in her heart I
never in a million years thought it was
heart attack honestly I thought I was
just like mucusy from you know what
smoke like two joints earlier in the day
but I hadn't smoked for hours at this
point but like four hours since I didn't
smoke so it wasn't even that I was like
what could it be
so finally you know I was like I said to
Jordyn and Emily I was like I couldn't I
was trying to sit up I was just trying
to breathe it's tough to catch my breath
you could breathe like shallow but if
you look for a deep breath it was like
like you had to get over a cliff there
was a hurdle for each deep breath so
finally I said to him I was just like do
me a favor maybe we should call a doctor
and they were ready the whole time to do
so and then they told me the like
there's an ambulance coming it's Sunday
night there's no doctors and stuff I'm
like an ambulance oh man for a minute I
was like oh man is embarrassing so the
paramedics came wonderful first
responders man they they they were very
patient with a guy who was never mind
the heart attack deathly afraid of
lifting his shirt up you know that's
part of the deal right some of the like
we've called the you know the paramedics
we got a check-in and stuff and they you
know put monitors on here or whatever
got to do your blood pressure so
instantly you know they start doing what
they do and lift you up your shirt and
I'm like oh my gag him down my shirt it
became a struggle a battle with these
cats because you know they looked at me
I was profusely sweating and I sweat
like when I [ __ ] breathe but this is
more than I've ever sweated in my life
so they're looking at me going like this
cat has no idea what's going on does he
and I'm like don't lift my shirt up
please and so they're talking to me and
asking me all the questions and [ __ ]
like that and you know I was like hey
man I I feel okay and they're like we
think you might be having a heart
episode right now so how about you know
we put these monitors on you so they did
and they did my blood pressure and then
they
guy was like I'm gonna put this is night
nitrous or Nitro whatever they call it
I'm gonna put it under your tongue lift
your tongue up and I did and he squirted
it under there that happened five more
times once he did that twice then I
started catching on to be like I wonder
if I wonder if this is worse than I
assumed and then I heard somebody in
there was like six people and I was too
busy like trying to keep my shirt down
to concentrate but one person said heart
attack and that's when I was like it
what no surely not like we're gonna take
you to the hospital just to make sure
you didn't have a heart attack and I was
like okay that's totally great and they
took me to the hospital it put me among
those chairs loaded me into the
ambulance and as I left I saw people I
think they were in line for the next
show and you know they were like do it
up cab because I guess the people at the
theater or the folks with comedy
dynamics who are shooting special with
told the crowd that I was a witch McCoy
I food poisoning they were like I
because you know that was the nearest
thing to configure the like what he
threw up I guess maybe had food
poisoning what in food poisoning so I
got an ambulance they brought me to the
to the closest hospital Glendale
Adventist and if you're ever going to
have some sort of heart episode for the
love of God have it in Glendale like
this hospital is I guess clearly well
they told me the like they're considered
one of the the best in the country for
cardiology and and my doctor Laden on
[ __ ] saved my life
he my boy man like yes it is where he
works they brought him in and stuff so
it was so they get me to the hospital
they get me the emergency room not now
the emergency room yeah the emergency
room first and you know they're shifting
me on the bed for people picking me up
and slide you over it's like all the
[ __ ] that you see you like on Grey's
Anatomy no no and so they're asking you
questions everything's moving at a brisk
pace
what's your name and I was like I'm
gonna get all these right Kevin Smith
like I'm good at this test well your
birthday where do you live from all that
stuff was your mom's name what was your
wife's name is so so you know I was
pretty much just in bed you know in the
ER and gone like I think it's gonna be
okay like
you know I just have some I can't catch
my breath they're like do you have
heaviness in your chest you feel like
like there's an elephant sitting on your
chest I was like no not an elephant I
said but like I I definitely have a hard
time catching my breath and so they put
me on monitors and all this [ __ ] and
then they're like okay
we're gonna take you up to the emergency
room and I was like what no like you've
had a major heart attack
massive was the word that if you've had
a massive heart attack and you're el-ad
is completely blocked hundred percent
blog or something like that so the like
we're gonna take you well they didn't
know that part yet they're like we're
gonna take you up to the ER Chris you've
got a massive heart attack and we have
to look inside your heart right away and
I was like how does that happen and you
know because they're starting to pump
you with some drugs and so they said
we're gonna go up through your groin and
into your heart and I've right then and
there I was like this [ __ ] is serious
son so I was like okay and I never got
scared like that at one point the one of
the paramedics was like you're being
real calm man that's great that's that's
that's gonna help a lot and then there
was someone else behind him it was like
that's what's gonna save his life and
little things like that I was like what
does that mean like I again I still
didn't know like what was going on so so
here's me in in the in the emergency
room dying literally dying and this was
my biggest concern guy comes in he goes
I'm not to shave your groin he take your
shirts off have to shave your groin I
said for what he goes they go up through
your grind to get into your heart and I
said I don't I don't want to do that
because you have to and I said well but
I don't I don't wanna my biggest fear in
life death number one number two people
see in my dick like that's that's it
terrified of that oh my god I've got on
my way my whole life to not let my
[ __ ] dick PC in [ __ ] never wanted to
go to a hospital or a doctor for that
very reason don't want to be judged
obviously small so it was funny I was
talking to doctor at one point today and
the doctor goes we were all talking
about it because I told him I was like I
was so scared people talk about my dick
he goes we were all talking about it's
huge
he's funny he's lying it ain't so the
guy goes I got to shave you and I said I
said
I can't do it he goes I gotta take your
underwear off I said bro if you take my
underwear off I will have another heart
attack right here like I can't I can't
do that because what are we supposed to
do and I said we show me where you got
to shave and so he showed me like in the
groin where it was and so I was making
deals with this dude I'm literally dying
and I'm making deals with this dude
going look how about I pull the
underwear over as far as I can and then
you get in there and shave and that way
I could keep my underwear on my man was
looking at me like okay bro I get it you
dicks mall so I did that I was and then
I remember them you know putting me on
to onto the elevator and taking me up to
the emergency room so I got into the
emergency room and as for dr. Layton
hime was guys saved my life and I said
hey man how are you and he goes how you
feelin looks like you had a heart attack
he's going we're gonna go up your groin
to see inside make sure the arteries
clear if it's not we're gonna put a
stent in there and all of this is
happening very fast and I know about
these things because my mom has two
stents and two of her arteries in her
heart my dad as previously mentioned
died of a massive heart attack so it's
in my family like genetically the doc
told me is like you can't like nothing
you can do about this
genetically speaking you were just dealt
these cards like I got the good and the
bad from mom and dad and you know they
made me who I am but they also gave me a
week ticker I guess or at least one
aspect of a week ticker so he goes up
and the whole time like you know they're
like we got to take your gear off and
they're taking my clothes off and
they're taking my jersey off and I'm
holding on to my Jersey as I can I can't
let go of this in my hat that was like I
know no you can't take that and they're
like bro you're dying so then they you
know ultimately who member at one point
somebody was like why is he have
underwear on still get him off and I was
arguing with him trying to hold him up
and stuff and then I took my shirt and I
was covering myself with it like a
modesty rag and whatnot and they were
like I finally somebody have a good
sense to be like he doesn't quite
realize that hiding his dick is not the
most important thing right now so they
went in there and run up my leg and with
my groin and and completely one end I
found the the el-ad was a hundred
percent blocked
put us
ten BAM Here I am crazy dude literally
saved my life isn't that nuts you know I
was like hey man I just lost like 85
pounds and I walk every day and stuff
like that and he's like yeah he's gone
as that's good but it is gone this
started a long time ago he's going like
you know all that plaque in that artery
and stuff he's going plus like because
of my genetics like a real thin artery
there or whatever [ __ ] so I you know
that's what happened and then they
brought me back to the room and and I
recovered all yesterday so I saw so many
nice well wishes from people online and
I just wanted to say thank you it was
wonderful it was kind of like like
yesterday reading all the people that
I've heard from people I haven't heard
from in years I read stuff online really
nice sweet things but it was kind of
like being like knowing or being there
reading your eulogy like I you know I I
saw what life will be like kind of when
I doubt what the reaction would be if I
died and it was very sweet like I felt
like all right on
you know most days I'm like most people
must think I'm an [ __ ] but yesterday
they didn't like there was a lot of
positive [ __ ] man and I remember I
remember like you know reading like kind
things from people who normally don't
say kind things about my me or my career
and I was like god dammit like this is
this is what's gonna be like when I die
one day like hopefully that people say
nice things and I realized as long as I
keep my nose clean from now until the
end as long as I don't wake up with like
you know they don't fire me with a dead
girl or a lot of boy I built they might
you know be kind at the end you know it
won't be one of these people won't be
one of these people to die with like
good riddance you fat [ __ ] it was very
very sweet so I heard from people I
haven't heard from him in a long time
heard from people I never heard from
before poor Chris Pratt one of my
favorite actors on the planet you know
if I can put up a nice tweet where he's
just like hey man I'll know you that
much but like I love clerks and I'm
praying for you and apparently like some
people like [ __ ] your prayers an attack
time and [ __ ] and then James Gunn had to
jump into it be like ain't nothing wrong
with prayin for a person man yes that in
number one oh my god thanks to Chris
Pratt how sweet was that star-lord
praying for me but number two yeah
please don't
over stuff like that it's a waste of
time um your prayer whether you're
religious or not somebody saying I'll
pray for you this is like good intention
it's very nice
especially because it's not like Chris
Pratt was like move over I'm gonna reach
my hands into his chest and save [ __ ]
song of Bob's life myself but uh it was
all of this very surprising is my point
wasn't expected some people like how I
saw online some people were like how
could he not have expected this like he
was too fat to fly guy I lost like 85 90
pounds since then so you know some [ __ ]
like I went through lifestyle changes
and some [ __ ] don't matter some [ __ ] you
just can't because its genetic so what
happens now what's gonna go what goes
forward apparently I've become I will
become a prescription man I'm gonna have
lots of pills I'm gonna be one of those
people like my mom
it's got pills all the time so they put
me on blood thinners they'll put me on
lipitor that put me on a beta blocker
and stuff like that and that's the
biggest change then I will start seeing
a cardiologist on a regular basis
because now I'm this guy but I'm very
Legum well like I'm not you know well I
am well like I'm sitting up talking and
walking around and [ __ ] like that
and a lot of people were you know I saw
online like this is gonna take a long
recovery and really it's not medical
science is so [ __ ] amazing man right
now
but I talked to dr. Leighton Heim today
and I was like I feel great and you know
he was like well you had a blocked el-ad
for who knows how long and stuff and so
now the blood is flowing and so I feel
like I'm on like a natural high um which
is true because I haven't smoked weed in
like two days
so for anybody who is like he's a weed
addict hey man 2 days went by I was not
thinking about weed whoa no I didn't
even think about weed now also not
thinking about food it's crazy I've lost
my appetite for a lot of stuff but I got
a zest for life and as I said in my
piece I wrote on Instagram and Facebook
there was this moment where I was like I
I'm I might die like all this talk and
like at one point somebody said get the
morphine and I was like morphine like
work wow I'm not that guy and she
in morphine and if they're pulling out
morphine that usually means bad [ __ ] so
when I heard that you know I started
going like this could be it this might
be it and so I thought about my life and
I thought about everything you know it's
not like my life flashed before my eyes
but I had a good long moment to think
you know and and like what did I want to
do do I want to bargain with God in that
moment be like please [ __ ] save me
and stuff like that
after dogma that was probably not gonna
happen so I just thought about
everything and thought about like you
know my parents and how they raised me
and and my brother and my sister and and
my friends and my wife and my kid and my
like this weird wonderful career that
I've had for so long and stuff and I was
like content like it was weird I'll not
to say that I didn't want to die don't
get me wrong but I was like well if the
ferryman comes tonight I gotta pay him
like what a ride it's been
what an incredible [ __ ] ride man so
there was calm so even as the dude was
like we're going up your groin and we're
good in your heart and I was like I was
calm it was weird I was always afraid
that I would be you know terrified of
dying I watched you know my dad didn't
see him die but was there when my dad
passed my brother actually saw him die
was there when my grandmother died like
I've seen people die and I was always
terrified like I liked life you like
life worked out for me and so I don't
ever want to let it go but in that
moment you know even though I was 47 and
stuff like that I was like well that
that'll do it like I that'll do Pig I
felt like I was babe I was like that'll
do Pig that'll do and I was not not I
was ready I was I was I was okay with it
I was bummed that we weren't getting it
get to make James obob reboot that was
the only big regret of course not seeing
my wife and kid and stuff like that that
goes without saying but professionally
speaking I was like only we had made
that movie that would have been a nice
one to go out so now we still got time
but there it is folks I'm fine
look at me I'm in my robe and [ __ ] I was
walking around the hospital and like
some of the nurses were like we all
think it's hysterical that you wear your
robe you got comfortable there
quick you've only been here 36 hours I
was like well so it's it's all good
thank you for your incredible well
wishes friends family people I've never
[ __ ] met it meant the world i sat
there reading tons of it yesterday
I'll read more of it today I was
supposed to be making the Goldbergs this
week direct in the season finale
unfortunately this is going to preempt
that they want me to just sit around the
house and convalesce for a week I'm not
allowed to drive and that [ __ ] weird
but other than that like I'm okay man
and mercifully jenny was here but she
slept here last night she slept on the
bed I slept here on I'm [ __ ] couch
thing but we're ready to go home dr.
Layton I'm came in cleared me man oh
this guy this guy's the Batman a [ __ ]
cardiologist man he was so calm and
[ __ ] he was like a vigilante he
wouldn't let that [ __ ] he was like he
sees that la dee he's like come here
Joker he stuffed him in [ __ ] Arkham
I'm using compactor me so people that
don't understand medicine will
understand this in any event so far so
good still standing folks thank you for
all your incredible well wishes and
whatnot and hopefully see you guys it
very soon I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
convalesce good talking to you